memo fight 2018 the Republicans take on
the FBI in the Royal Rumble plus Mika
Brzezinski throws Michael wolf off the
set of Morning Joe and Republicans
should read books and I will show you an
example why I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show we'll bring you the
latest on memo gate 2018 memo fight is
the most exciting rumble in the history
of American politics
everybody's gonna just show up from the
from the bit from the the side of the
stage and just Club each other with
reams of paper it'll be so exciting
Devon Nunez versus Adam Schiff face off
Nancy Pelosi versus Paul Ryan pounding
to the mat it's gonna be in crowd will
discuss all of those things first I'm
gonna put you to sleep with a bull and
branch ad because the fact is if you
need to relax folks then you need to
sleep well I am NOT somebody who tends
to sleep well particularly when I'm on
the road but when I'm at home I do sleep
well and that's because of bull and
branch eats they are the best sheets in
the business bowl and bran sheets will
cost like a thousand bucks in the store
this kind of quality of sheep roll and
bran sheets though are only a couple of
hundred dollars we we tried them we love
them so much that we were placed pretty
much all the sheets in our house with
bull and branch sheets because they are
top quality they're made from pure 100%
organic cotton they start out soft and
they get even softer over time right now
my listeners get $50 off their first set
of sheets at bull and branch calm promo
code been use that promo code been Bo LL
and branch calm promo code been again
the sheets are just a terrific there's a
reason three u.s. presidents have slept
on bull and branch sheets and shipping
is free you can even try them for 30
nights if you don't like them send it
back for a refund but no one wants to
send it back for a refund because they
are that good you don't think about
cheap quality until you've actually
slept in really good sheets and then
once you do you never want to go back so
ball and branch calm promo club Ben you
get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets ball and branch calm use that
promo code Ben okay so again okay I'm
just excited to say memo fight and memo
gate and it's all it's all so exciting
in truth none of it is all that exciting
I'm gonna try and break down what's
happening here because if it seems like
always chaos and confusion if it feels
like the Aurora Bros of confusion and
cast has taken over your life haven't
hang out with Jordan Peterson too much
then you need to yeah we're gonna try
and break down and separate out all of
the various strands
of what's going on in the FBI scandal
and who's to blame and who is lying
okay so first let's begin with this the
FBI is basically asking you to trust
them and the Republicans are asking you
to trust them and the Democrats are
asking you to trust the FBI and
President Trump is asking you to trust
the Republicans and you don't know who
to trust because the truth is we don't
have all the information what we do know
is a couple of things there are a few
different strains here strand number one
the FBI in all likelihood acted
corruptly in allowing Hillary Clinton to
get away with storing classified
information on a private unsecured email
server okay that was FBI malfeasance and
it was probably planned by the Obama
administration in coordination with the
DOJ and the FBI there's pretty solid
evidence to that effect I talked about
it a few days ago on the show if you go
back about a week and listen to my show
in which I discuss the Andrew McCarthy's
piece over at National Review laying out
the case that there was essentially
coordination between the Obama team in
the White House and the FBI to let
Hillary Clinton off the hook
specifically because Hillary was
illegally storing classified information
on her server and using a private email
address and Obama was emailing her at
that email address meaning he knew that
she was using a private email address
for classified material which was not in
fact legal that that piece by McCarthy
is pretty damning and pretty telling
about what the FBI was doing and now we
know according to The Wall Street
Journal is breaking news yesterday top
FBI officials were aware for at least a
month before alert in Congress that
emails potentially related to an
investigation of Hillary Clinton had
emerged during a key stretch of the 2016
presidential campaign according to text
messages reviewed by the Wall Street
Journal
so FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe had
learned about the thousands of emails by
September 28th 2016 director James Comey
informed Congress on October 28th 11
days before the presidential elections
but the but mr. Comey said nothing Comey
later said nothing about how early he
had known about those emails we went a
month without hearing about those things
so Democrats were complaining that Comey
sandbag Hillary Clinton in all
likelihood what happened here is the
Comey felt it was necessary because
they'd actually gone through they'd
reviewed a lot of these emails and they
were seeing some stuff they didn't like
but that took them a month to announce
to Congress so when people talk about
corruption inside the FBI when they talk
about the gaming of the FBI by the by
the Obama administration there's some
pretty good evidence for that and so
it's hard to trust the FBI when the FBI
says
release this four-page memo about Trump
Russia collusion now Devin Nunez the
House Intelligence Committee he's put
together a four page memo this
much-ballyhooed memo from the House
Intelligence Committee that details
intelligence malfeasance not just in the
Hillary Clinton investigation but also
supposedly in the Trump Russia collusion
investigation and this has been seen now
by a lot of conservatives has served the
last great hope to save Trump from the
Mueller investigation and this I think
is an oversell we know that the FBI was
acting in bad faith on Hillary Clinton
we don't know that the FBI was acting on
been in bad faith on the Trump Russian
collusion stuff and one of the weird
things about this whole memo routine as
I've said is Trump can declassify all of
the underlying materials that the memo
supposedly contemplates he can do that
right now but he hasn't instead he's
allowing the Republicans to charge
around at this four page memo talk about
how this memo is the smoking gun that
shows that the investigation into Trump
himself has been corrupted and ruined
from the very outset well the FBI has
has now responded to the house
intelligence committees votes to release
the memo by expressing grave concern
over the memos accuracy so the FBI
released a statement on Wednesday they
said they had quote-unquote grave
concerns about the accuracy from a top
secret top secret House Intelligence
Committee memo alleging anti-trump bias
within the Justice Department
challenging that president Trump's
pledge to release it but a few hours
after the Republic rebuked by the top US
law enforcement agency a trump
administration official said the memo
was likely to be released today on
Thursday the FBI said in a statement
quote the FBI was provided a limited
opportunity to review this memo the day
before the committee voted to release it
as expressed during our initial review
we have grave concerns about material
emissions of fact that fundamentally
impact the memos accuracy so the FBI
released the statement presumably you
would figure Christopher rage from stone
appointee at the FBI had reviewed the
statement before it went out so even he
doesn't think this memo should be
released and a compromises national
security so now the question is this do
you believe the House committee do you
believe that the Republicans on the
House committee who say we need to get
this information out there the FBI acted
corruptly or do you believe the FBI
saying that it's dangerous to release
this memo and in fact the memo skews the
facts which one do you believe now it's
almost impossible to tell who to believe
because we haven't seen the memo right
we haven't actually seen the underlying
memo and more than that we haven't seen
any of the underlying materials in the
memo so we're fighting everyone's
right now over a memo that none of us
have seen and we've heard secondhand
accounts so this is basically an
argument from authority on all sides so
the worst kind of argument the worst
kind of argument is the argument from
Authority the one that says you know it
doctor or so-and-so said X therefore X
is true right no that's that's not a
convincing argument
Devon Nunez said X therefore X is true
is no more convincing argument than Adam
Schiff said X therefore X is true or
trump said X therefore X is true or the
FBI said X therefore X is true if you
don't know what X is it's impossible for
you to independently judge whether X is
true or not and I don't trust any of
these people enough to know whether I
believe their accounts of what's
actually in the memo or what happened on
front pressure collusion or any of the
rest of it my own personal supposition
is that the memos materials about
Hillary Clinton are probably pretty
damning the memos materials about the
Trump campaign and an FBI investigation
of the Trump campaign would probably be
less so the allegation presumably noonas
sort of newness said this yesterday the
allegation is that the FBI utilized the
steal dossier which was the the Oppo
research dossier gathered by fusion GPS
a democratic Oppo intelligence firm at
the behest of Hillary Clinton that the
FBI got a hold of that Apple research
file and used it to open a FISA warrant
on Carter page a trump foreign policy
adviser and that's what launched the
entire Trump Russia collusion probe and
so Republicans are saying that's corrupt
you use democratic research basically
funneled by Russia to open the Trump
Russia probe in the first place but I'm
not sure there's a huge case for that
you know I would probably think that
they they based their original FISA
application on more than just the the
dossier if they base it on just the
dossier that's a problem but even then
there was a FISA warrants out for Carter
page you know tapping his phone since
2014 so Carter page has been on the
FBI's radar long before President Trump
was an issue and long before he was on
Trump's campaign so in any case just
because the FBI did stuff wrong and the
Clinton investigation doesn't
necessarily mean they did anything wrong
in the Trump Russia investigation and
Republicans by tying the two together by
suggesting the FBI screwed up the
Clinton investigation therefore they're
out to get Trump saying that is is a
jump it's a logical leap and it makes
Republicans look like they're actually
trying to take down the FBI in order to
protect Trump as opposed to looking at
the facts on the ground now Democrats on
there have been saying that the FBI is
clean all the way through so they look
like partisan hacks as well so the
Republicans look like partisan hacks by
tying together what we know about FBI
malfeasance on Hillary and what we don't
know about FBI malfeasance on Trump and
the Democrats look like hacks by saying
the FBI is clean and pure as the driven
snow and has been all along so again
this leaves us with the who do you trust
scenario now the the Trump
administration is now telling major
Garrett over at CBS News that the memo
is not going to be approved today that
it will instead be sent back to House
Intelligence Committee tomorrow with
roads actions from the White House based
on internal consultations with the FBI
and other agencies so the FBI gave
advice and the Trump administration will
take that advice and strike out some of
the language and then the White House
will not release the memo but send it
back to the committee for its release on
its own timetable meaning that they
would vote again to release the memo and
then Trump wouldn't say anything and
then after five days it would come out
which means that we drag this into next
week I'll explain what that means
politically and I will also go through
the battle that has ensued over the memo
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at man
crates man crates calm this is the best
place to find amazing gifts that your
man will love and ladies gentlemen we're
not going to discriminate based on
sexual orientation if you have a man
that you love in your life or you maybe
have a father a brother if you haven't
somebody in your life who's a man the
best gift that you can get them is a man
crate and the reason is because these
are curated gift collections for every
type of guy from sports fanatics to home
chefs to outdoorsmen and they come in
these amazing crates or ammo boxes the
crates actually send you an engraved
crowbar and you break open the box to
get to the gift so you really have to be
a man to do it and then they also send
over that you can get an ammo crate as
well and the ammo crate has the gift
inside so for example we have one right
over here
this yes you see it look at this this
right here it's a man crate and inside
this man crate are a bunch of poker
chips so this is this is one of their
their gifts I actually just got
something that didn't come in the crate
I was confused by it because I didn't
come and create but it is awesome and
then as a personalized guitar with my
name on it now you asked do I play
guitar the answer of course is no I do
not play guitar but now my wife will
love me even more you
as I learned in high school if you have
a guitar the chicks love you so it does
not even matter if you can play you just
carry it around and look brooding and it
should be awesome so that is my dad
that's the the what I'm gonna try
tonight with my man crate gift
so check out man crates calm pick the
perfect gift and then wait for the best
moment go to man crates calm slash pin
you get five percent off they don't
offer a discount anywhere else so you
have to go to man crates calm slash Bend
right now that's man crates calm slash
Ben as you can tell I am very
enthusiastic about man crate so go check
it out man crates calm slash Ben it's an
awesome gift it's it's really fun and
they have a great variety of stuff that
you can get for the man in your life who
likes to break things and every man in
your life I promise you if you think
they don't like to break things they all
love to break things okay so let's it
back to it back to memo 52018 I'm using
this voice all day long
memo 52018 so now we know according to
major Garrett that the White House will
not in fact release the memo today the
memo will be released presumably next
week right then next week we'll find out
the next week we'll find out what
exactly is in the memo and as I say I
think that it's overblown on pretty much
every side but you can see the two sides
battling it out so representative mark
meadows remember the freedom caucus
representative from I believe North
Carolina he comes out he says Devon
Nunez who is the head of the House
Intelligence Committee he has a duty to
inform Congress about abuses and that's
why the memo was written chairman Nunez
has an obligation an obligation to
inform Congress when there has been FISA
abuses and so all he's doing is falling
on his constitutional duty to let us
know about that okay so that is the
Republican attempt to to justify the
memo and then the Democrats say don't
release the memo now when the Democrats
say don't release mm oh it makes
Republicans who become somewhat
conspiratorial on this think well there
must be something in it they don't want
seen right why wouldn't they want to
release the memo like we're not gonna
take Democrats in good faith when
Democrats say we want to protect the
intelligence community if there is a
certain irony to the Democrats yelling
and screaming about protecting the FBI
when they spent years under Bush ripping
the CIA and the rest of the intelligence
community up and down all the time all
over right suddenly the FBI are the best
friends but this is the attack the
Democrats are gonna take Joe Manchin
Democrat from West Virginia senator he
says don't release the memo would you
say that the Pres
it's wrong to release that memo I was
definitely mr. president quiz nothing do
that that is wrong it is absolutely
wrong first of all people even revealed
his sources Devon Nunez okay this is a
man that was sanctioned by his own
committee members that he couldn't be on
the Russian probe this is a person
basically this kind of shoots from the
hip and I said he is Nunez has neutered
the credibility of this Intelligence
Committee on the House the Senate
Intelligence Committee is the only thing
that we have left that can put
confidence into the system and also into
the investigation so Nunez Nunez stood
to recall Nunez back in April went and
visited the White House and there he saw
documents that he said suggested the
members of the Obama administration had
unmasked members of the Trump
administration in FISA warrant
situations so unmasking is a process
whereby when when officials first get
reads on wiretaps that that are between
foreign agents foreign people who are
wiretapping in American citizens the
names of the American citizens are
hidden to protect the privacy the
members of the administration can ask
for those names to be unmasked Susan
Rice presumably did that with Mike Flynn
the former national security adviser
when he was talking with members of the
Russian government or members of the
Turkish government and Devon Nunez said
this was a misuse of her authority and
then he was sort of forced to recuse
himself he didn't technically recuse
himself but he sort of recused himself
from the Russia investigation but he
maintained that he was going to continue
looking into FBI malfeasance with regard
to for example obstruction of justice as
well as the Hillary investigation so all
this gets rather complicated but suffice
to say the new Nia Nunez is a is a
controversial character and Democrats
are seizing on that Adam Schiff Democrat
from California he's been leading the
charge every day the Trump Russia
collusion is real he goes on CNN
routinely it's like he has an office
staked out there at CNN he has his own
green room just labeled with his name
Adam chef and he has been saying every
day Trump Russia collusion Israel now he
says that to release this memo would
smear the FBI sadly we can fully expect
that the president United States will
not put the national interest over his
own personal interest but it is a sad
day indeed when that is also true of our
own committee because today this
committee voted to put the president's
personal interest
their own political interest above the
national interest in denying themselves
even the ability to hear from the
department and the FBI and that is I
think a deeply regrettable state of
affairs but it does show how in my view
when you have a deeply flawed person in
the Oval Office that flaw can infect the
whole of government and it's a today
tragically it infected our committee so
Schiff is gifted and making it sound
like partisan talking points are not in
fact partisan talking points but this is
in fact a partisan talking point we
don't know whether the memo smears the
FBI because we haven't seen the memo and
we don't know whether the FBI is
defending itself by trying to keep the
memo hidden we just don't know Democrats
of course are suggesting that the only
reason the Republicans are one released
the memo is to kill the molar
investigation now Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan has suggested that the memo is
important because it reveals FISA that
it reveals FBI abuses in the Hillary
investigation but this isn't necessarily
an attempt to stop the the Muller
investigation and I think it's an
important distinction if Republicans
were making that distinction day in and
day out they'd have a lot more
credibility on this issue they are not
making that distinction they are making
it sound as though if the FBI did the
wrong thing on Hillary Clinton that
means we have to stop the Muller
investigation that makes it look like
they are wielding their their evidence
of failure by the FBI in the Hillary
investigation in order to protect Trump
from his own collusion or from his own
potential criminality that's exactly
what representative jackie speier
democrat said about the Republican
attempts to release this memo but you're
saying this morning that there is
dangerous classified information and yes
it should not be released
absolutely and why are the Republicans
going to lose because the president
wants to pursue this idea that somehow
the dossier was related that the dossier
is representative of why this whole
investigation began okay so this is the
the Democratic take on all this now the
Democrats have been trying really hard
to stop the memo from coming out and so
last night Adam Schiff came out and he
said that the memo should not be
released because the version of the memo
those approved by the House Intelligence
Committee was not the version of the
memo that was sent to the White House he
said that Devon Nunez actually changed
the memo itself and then sent it to the
White House so he released a letter and
he tweeted out breaking discovered late
tonight that chairman Nunez
material changes to the metal he sent to
the White House change is not approved
by the committee White House therefore
reviewing a document the committee has
not approved for release so Trump is
attempting to prevent the the stalemate
here by just sending the memo back to
the House Intelligence Committee
essentially Nunez responded by slapping
at Schiff and suggesting that instead
quote and there's what Nunez says his
spokesperson quote and it's increasingly
strange attempt to thwart publication of
the memo the committee minority is now
complaining about minor edits to the
memo including grammatical fixes into
edits requested by the FBI and by the
minority themselves and then they
continued by suggesting and so Schiff
had said that Nunez made substance of
changes but Nunez spokesperson says
quote the vote to release the memo was
absolutely procedurally sound and in
accordance with House and committee
rules to suggest otherwise but to start
a bizarre distraction from the abuses
detailed in the memo so all of this I
understand is really confusing it's
really confusing why there but here's
the bottom line
Republicans either want this memo out
because they want to discredit the FBI
with regards to the FBI investigation
into Hillary Clinton or they want this
memo out because they think it's gonna
end the Moller investigation if the
latter we must see evidence if the
latter we must see evidence otherwise
it's just a cover-up attempt it
meanwhile if the memo comes out and it
does show evidence of these things and
Democrats were trying to cover-up the
memo then that is to a partisan hack
attempt to protect the FBI's that the
FBI can continue its investigation into
Trump and if it turns out there's
evidence of FBI malfeasance on Trump
Russia collusion then and the FBI was
using national security as an excuse to
shut down public knowledge of that fact
then that would demonstrate a certain
level of corruption inside the FBI as
well so bottom line is this either
somebody's lying or everybody's lying
there's no situation in which nobody is
lying either the Republicans are lying
when they say that the FBI has been
compromised and they are just trying to
cover for Trump or the Democrats are
lying when they say the FBI is crystal
clean and quote crystal clear and
therefore and therefore any attempt to
shut down any investigation is an
attempt to protect Trump so somebody is
lying here or it's possible everybody's
a little bit lying it's possible then
Republicans are telling the truth about
the FBI and Hillary but lying about the
FBI on Trump Russia it's possible the
Democrats are telling the truth about
the FBI and Trump Russia but lying about
Trump hill about the FBI and Hillary
it's possible that Trump doesn't know
what's going on it's possible Trump
knows fully what's going on
and thinks that this is gonna be an
excuse for him to fire the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein or to
get rid of people inside the FBI who are
involved in the Muller investigation we
just don't know yet
so as I've been saying now for a couple
of weeks it is imperative that we sit
and wait for the answer okay this is not
something where we can where we can just
jump to particular conclusions
especially not having seen the
underlying documents and not having seen
the underlying classified material it
does make me suspicious by the way that
the White House is sending the memo back
with FBI changes and not just releasing
it now that's suspicious simply because
I think that what it looks like is is
the White House doesn't want to have its
fingerprints on this thing but the White
House is gonna have its fingerprints on
this thing no matter what the media I
think are rightly going to assume that
the Trump administration was
coordinating with the Republican House
Intelligence Committee and coming up
with this memo I'd be shocked if there
was no coordination again if you just
reverse the situation pretend that these
were Democrats doing this I'd be just as
suspicious so I'm trying to be a little
bit objective here if the Democrats if
Hillary Clinton were under investigation
by the FBI for collusion with a foreign
country or for obstruction of justice
and then the Democrats came up with a
four page memo suggesting that the
intelligence community was responsible
it's for the deep state was out to get
Hillary Clinton I would think the same
thing Democrats are thinking today this
smells the smells so that means the
burden on Republicans to come out with
some natural evidence here is pretty
high particularly when you have all the
Republicans rushing to the microphones
to explain that this memo is going to
change everything that it's going to
change everything well in just a second
I'm gonna explain a couple more scandals
that are brewing yes believe it or not
more scandals brewing because it just
never stopped it just doesn't stop but
first I don't say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
you have heard me talk about the glories
of the Dollar Shave Club raiser which as
I say I use on my neck I can't use it
above the the jaw line for Jewish ritual
purposes however other people in the
office also use Dollar Shave Club the
shave is just phenomenal from Dollar
Shave Club and they have everything
right it's not just razors anymore they
have dr. Carver's shave butter they also
have products for your hair for your
face for your skin for your shower they
have me looking and feeling amazing look
you just look at me I'm incredible
looking okay that's because of dr. of
Dollar Shave club's products okay and I
smell great as well you can't smell me
through the camera if you could
it's devastating I am just I smell
fantastic and that is because of Dollar
Shave Club and me using their products I
use Dollar Shave Club for pretty much
everything I have the razors I have the
body cleanser I have the hair gel and
yes in the Shapiro household do we even
have the fabled long sought-after butt
wipes ok so right now is a great time to
give Dollar Shave Club a try ok your
first month their best razor along with
travel sized version of shea butter body
cleanser and yes even the fabled
somewhat mythical butt wipes for just $5
in a mythical they're very real they're
very real but they've materialized after
thousands of years of people telling of
their glories after that the replacement
cartridges ship for just a few bucks a
month into the DSE starter side get
yours for just $5 exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben go and
check it out right now it makes a good
Valentine's Day gift for the guy in your
life so dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
and again when you use the slash Ben you
get the first month of their best razor
along with travel sized versions of the
shave butter the body cleanser and the
incredible butt wipes for just $5 and
then just a few bucks a month after that
to keep the cartridges at coming so it's
a lot less expensive than going to your
local store and picking up all of these
products so check it out
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben use the
slash Ben it's that they know that we
say you okay other scandals a Bruin so
one of the other scandals that broke
late last night is that mark Corallo was
a former Trump legal spokesperson is
planning on telling Robert Mueller
according to the New York Times about a
previously undisclosed conference call
which led him to believe that hope Hicks
is a special aides of the President of
the United States was going to obstruct
justice so here is what the New York
Times says quote mr. Corey o Corallo is
planning to tell mr. Muller about a
previously undisclosed conference call
with mr. Trump and hope Hicks the White
House communications director according
to three people mister Corallo planned
to tell investigators that Miss Hicks
said during the call that emails written
by Donald Trump jr. before the Trump
Tower meeting in which the younger mr.
Trump said he was eager to receive
political dirt about mrs. Clinton from
the Russians quote we'll never get out
that left mr. Corallo with concerns that
Miss Hicks could become contemplating
obstructing justice that people said in
a statement on Wednesday a lawyer from
his six strongly denied mr. Corallo the
allegations so she is denying she's as
she is suggesting that this is untrue
even if the allegation is true that she
said it would never get out that's not
an implication necessarily I mean this
would be the
legal-defense pirate a lawyer it's not
necessarily meaning I'm gonna destroy
the documents it just might be nobody's
ever gonna discover that these emails
exist right how are they gonna know is a
closed loop but with all of that said
they obviously did come out and if it
turns out that the Trump administration
knew about the emails from Trump jr. to
a Russian connected lawyer offering
Russian help in the election and that
the Trump administration then was
complicit in destroying materials then
you do fall foul of obstruction laws
construction actually requires
destruction of documents under one of
the statutory frameworks and that means
that if the Trump administration tried
to destroy materials that could very
well be obstruction Trump may not be
complicit in that but if hope Hicks gets
rolled up into that then you could see
how pics getting rolled up and Donald
Trump jr. getting rolled up things could
get very ugly very quickly in other
words if this story is true hole picks
is denying it so we'll see how that
plays out meanwhile there's another
story coming out I mean so many leaks a
new report from CNN Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein was essentially
asked if he was loyal to the president
when the DOJ official visited the White
House last month to seek assistance from
the president Rosen Stein had gone there
to ask if Trump could help him stave off
document demands from house Intel
committee chair Devin Nunez first of all
I don't know why Rosen Stein was asking
that why not just had the documents over
to Nunez but the president apparently
according to CNN had other priorities
ahead of a key appearance by Rosen Stein
on the hill Trump wanted to know where
the special counsels Russian
investigation was heading and he wanted
to know whether Rosen Stein was
quote-unquote on my team okay so that's
not a giant surprise presumably he'd
asked James Comey if if he was loyal to
Trump and of all of the things that
Trump has said this is the one that I
find may be least objectionable just
because not to do a little bit of bad
ism but here's some what about ISM Eric
Holder was the Attorney General for
Barack Obama and went around openly
calling himself Barack Obama's wingman
so the idea that the FBI deputy director
is somehow completely separate from the
sorry not to be the director for the FBI
but the but that the DOJ assistant
attorney general the Deputy Attorney
General is somehow not supposed to be
loyal to the President of the United
States if that were true I would like to
hear where the Democrats were when Eric
Holder was pledging loyalty openly on
camera to Barack Obama
I'd like to know where everybody's ire
was then
so there's gonna be an attempt here to
suggest that Trump was asking for
loyalty test because he's trying to
quash the mother investigation again in
order to show obstruction you actually
have to show an attempted obstruction
asking people whether they are loyal is
not an attempt at obstruction firing
people who work for you is not an
attempt at obstruction an attempted
obstruction is when you actually are
number one attempting to obstruct the
investigation so if he would tell Muller
that the investigation must find him
innocent or he will be fired that would
be obstruction or if he destroyed
documents that would be obstruction if
he fires Muller it's not even clear
that's obstruction because he does have
the statutory authority to do that
right is that criminal obstruction maybe
not probably impeachable but it's not
necessarily criminal obstruction okay so
that's the the another piece of news on
the scandal front furthermore you can
see that the FBI is trying to restore
its own credibility after all the
accusations of bias in the Hillary
Clinton probe according to CNN emails
obtained by CNN show that Peter struck
the FBI agent at the center of a Capitol
Hill storm played a key role in a
controversial FBI decision that upended
Hillary Clinton's campaigns just days
before the 2016 election in the letter
to Congress by then FBI director James
Comey announcing the bureau was
investigating a newly discovered clean
email so apparently struck drafted the
original draft of the of the letter that
Comey ended up sending to Congress that
ended up probably affecting the outcome
of the election right so that is you
know that is a new piece of information
and the idea here is to sort of
rehabilitate struck the ideas that
struck wasn't corrupt struck wasn't out
to save Hillary Clinton he wrote the
letter that reopened the investigation
into Hillary Clinton but that does not
tell the whole story because it's also
true that struck had expressed his
doubts about whether the investigation
should go forward or the importance of
the new emails that were found you know
he did work for Comey stuff Comey wanted
that letter drafted he had to draft a
letter I mean that's sort of his job the
the real problem for struck is the is
the text messages exchanged between him
and his lover Lisa page showing that
struck was openly talking about how
Hillary Clinton needed to be let off the
hook because she might be president at
some point okay so with all of this in
the wind one of the worst things that
can happen to the country right now is
the is the level of vitriol to which
this is now risen right because we're
talking about the destruction of the FBI
as a credible institution we're talking
about the destruction of both political
parties as credible institutions and
everybody needs to turn down the
rhetoric a little
unfortunately they're just turning it up
Steve King from Iowa a Republican from
Iowa he says that again this is the
noonas memo is earth-shaking it is worse
than Watergate we are about to find out
that the entire deep state was out to
get Trump we're gonna have it at
Congress that does oversight we can't
accept the FBI or the DOJ or any other
branch of government from closing the
gate in front of us is saying sorry you
can't look at this because it's
classified and then what I saw and what
I believe happened could go on in
perpetuity and we become a Banana
Republic what this is earth-shaking and
it does go deeper than Watergate and
that memo doesn't at all wider kitty
means how is it deeper than deeper than
Watergate at it how is it deeper because
the FBI and the DOJ buy the information
that I have observed and the testimony
that I have I'm gonna say the testimony
that I have analyzed from listening to
and questioning multiple members of the
FBI and the DOJ tells me that that FBI
and DOJ have been weaponized okay so
that's a pretty that's pretty strong
allegation by Steve King of course and
then on the other side you have Phil
Mudd the the national security analyst
for CNN and he loses it about the noonas
memos again the rhetoric here is so hot
and it's so high and the reality is
nobody's seen the memo nobody knows what
they're talking about Steve King may
have read the memo but Steve King is
also a partisan Republican so that means
you haven't seen it I haven't seen it so
we have no basis for judgment all we
have are these people who either trust
or we don't trust here is Phil Mudd
presenting the opposite point of view
and going nuts over the name in his memo
give me a break I'm going to break the
camera here in a moment Aaron have you
ever worked in Washington DC I've worked
at the highest levels of the FBI the CIA
worked on the National Security Council
in the White House in the midst of the
highest profile investigation of
political corruption we've seen since
the 1970s in the midst of a precedent of
cooperation between the Congress
including Devin unius in the White House
do you think it was a secret that
congressional officials were preparing a
memo of this import and nobody knew at
the White House you've got to be kidding
me I'm gonna tell you the moons made of
green cheese I'm not saying there was
cooperation I'm not saying there's
collusion I'm saying in that small town
of Washington DC that to suggest that
nobody at the White House knew that
congressional
staffers were discussing a memo of this
import is that's ridiculous
it's not about whether Devin Nunez
coordinated it's whether somebody knew
over a cup of coffee and talked about it
and to tell me they didn't is just
stupid okay so everybody is going nuts
over this stuff we will find out we'll
find out by next week let's put it this
way if the if the memo turns out to it
be a giant nothing
the blowback will be very intense if the
memo turns out to be nothing and it
turns out that the Trump administration
was attempting to set up the memo as a
way to take down the Moller
investigation there will be intense
blowback and it will be deserved if the
Republicans decide that they went
forward with the memo that was an
attempt to take down the Muller
investigation or if they mailed off the
way they have been for the past few
weeks it's such a mistake you know in
business and in life there's a simple
rule that allows you to to lead a
happier life under-promise over-deliver
right say just say say what the memo is
right there's what Paul Ryan I think was
rightly trying to do the memo is about
FBI malfeasance in the Hillary Clinton
investigation and other FBI malfeasance
and when you see the memo you'll know
whether it's important or not and let it
speak for itself
but instead everybody pitches what
they're doing and that means that if
they pitch more than they can deliver
there's gonna be a lot of disappointed
disappointment and disappointment in
politics is absolute poison okay well in
just a second we will get to some things
I like and some things that I hate and
also an amazing segment on MSNBC but for
all of that you're gonna have to go over
to daily wire.com and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you can get your
subscription to daily wire that means
you get my show live to get Andrew
klevens fabulous show live get Michael
moles is mediocore show live we get all
of those live it's be part of my mailbag
tomorrow so you get to ask all of your
questions and you get to see all of our
all of our exclusive videos and and all
of our subscriber offers and if you get
the annual subscription you also get
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr unparalleled and no one can even
compete with it it is just that grand so
you know if you are considering other
tumblers do not this is the one that you
want so check that out if you just want
to listen later go over to SoundCloud
iTunes stitcher any of the any of the
podcast apps will have our podcast
because of course we are the largest
fastest core and conservative podcast in
the nation
all righty so the in other news the
media are beginning to realize that they
may be out over their skis on the
Michael Wolf book so Michael Wolf's fire
and fury has turned out to be a load of
trash which we said essentially at the
time it is very juicy load of trash but
it is trash nonetheless and so Michael
Wolfe the author of fire and fury which
is now sold something like 2 million
copies is promoted at the Grammys by
Hillary Clinton it's been promoted by
every major media outlet it was treated
as a serious work even though it was
completely fictionalized in parts and it
was basically as told by Steve Bannon
even a Saturday Night Live I think
rightly mocked said Michael Wolfe as
sort of a Steve Danon
tool in writing fire and fury well
Michael Wolfe appears on MSNBC this
morning says earlier this morning and
and Wolfe had implied over the last
couple of weeks that nikki Haley was
having an affair with President Trump
like this was the actual implication
which is just ridiculous there's no
evidence of that whatsoever and finally
finally Mika Brzezinski has had enough
and here's how that goes the wait are
you suggesting that I suggest think the
language is not ambiguous in any way and
the things that you've said in the way
you've stated are you kidding you're on
the side of Morning Joe we don't BS here
what's read me the language are you
kidding me I'm not reading you and play
the bill if you don't get it I'm sorry
this is awkward
you're here on the set with us but we're
done Michael Wolfe thank you we're gonna
go to break now so Brzezinski throws a
month the set because it's sexist
everything about Maneki Haley is sexist
but implying that Trump was a crazy
person all of that was totally inbounds
and it was the spirit of it was true
Mika Brzezinski two weeks ago said that
Michael Wolf's book has problems but the
spirit of the book is true this is the
problem with building up crazy people
like Michael Wolfe the problem building
up bad sources like Michael Wolfe
okay the reality is that Michael Wolfe
is a smear merchant he always was a
smear merchant and one of the funniest
things of the day is watching Michael
Wolfe go after he he is he's now going
after Mika Brzezinski he's actually
tweeting out he tweeted out earlier
today quote let me repeat nikki Haley
has chosen to vociferous Lee denies
something she was not accused of and she
said my bad the president is right about
Mika right now remember the press
the United States instead of mica was a
liar and that she had come to him with a
bloody face and he didn't want her at
her at his event because her face was
bloody and he wasn't really the trump
went after mica Hart now Michael Wolfe
who was built up by mica Brzezinski is
very very angry since the last time I
was on Morning Joe off-camera Joe and
mica eager to gossip about who Trump
might be sleeping with he said it would
really be hard to gossip more eagerly
off camera than mica and Joe gossip so
this snake in the grass this is the
problem with letting a snake into your
house eventually he's gonna bite you and
that's exactly what happened - Mika
Brzezinski so Mika is getting all sorts
of plaudits she did the right thing here
obviously but why was it that for
literally weeks Mika and the rest of the
media we're building up Michael wolf and
this just shows you know there are two
types of bias in the media I'm biased
number one in the media a piece of piece
of bias number one of the media is the
the notion that you can bias a story
right that a story comes through and you
read it in the in the most ridiculous
possible sense and the most anti
conservative possible sense that's one
form of bias the other form of bias is
to have on a series of guests who will
all do that for you so having Michael
Wolf on MSNBC is one example of this
another example of this Ellen DeGeneres
just had on Michelle Obama why is
Michelle Obama on with Ellen DeGeneres
why is she relevant the answer is she's
not right she's not launching a new
program now she's not doing anything
important she's just doing her first
interview since she left the White House
but here's what Michelle Obama said and
this came out this morning quote people
are afraid but then there are people who
feel good about the direction of the
country so I mean that's what makes this
country complicated because it's made up
of so many different people from
different backgrounds and that's what
that's what she told DeGeneres when
asked what advice she would give to
people who find the world to be a scary
place right now she said the thing I
learned in the eight years I was in the
White House is that what we do everyday
in our lives the good things that we do
every day and we know we do it we show
empathy we care for each other you know
we do have a lot in common that's what
it means to leave with hope and not fear
I would just encourage your viewers the
country to do the things we do every day
to love each other to take care of each
other to show empathy and you can't do
that only when people make you feel good
or safe we've got to do it all across
the board we have to be an open hearted
nation that's who we are so this is
another form of biases have on Michelle
Obama too to just lecture us PAP about
empathy by the way I have said many
times before empathy and politics is
poison sympathy is useful empathy is
the reason empathy is wrong is because
when you put yourself in somebody's
shoes you're immediately taking yourself
out of everyone else's shoes right if
you have empathy for one person that
means that you are feeling what that
person is feeling but you're not feeling
what the other 300 million people in the
country are feeling making policy should
not be based on empathy and it is
telling the sort of language Michelle
Obama uses where with the good things
that we do we show empathy we care for
each other those are not good things
that we do those may be good things that
we feel but the good things that we do
actually have to have good benefits
right I mean if you're gonna do
something good you have to benefit
somebody but it's all intent and no
delivery for so many for so many folks
on the left but this is just another
form of bias another form of bias Jimmy
Kimmel had on directly after the State
of the Union address the guys from pod
save America right and and and he had on
all of these folks from from a left-wing
podcast all former Obama staffers by the
way and I listened positive America I
find it amusing and I think sometimes
they have interesting insights I'd like
to hear a different perspective but the
idea that Jimmy can will ever have me on
ever in a million years our listenership
is about the same size as pod save
America's by the way because we
broadcast more often so we have the same
number of listeners in aggregate the
positive America does would they even in
a million years consider having me on to
talk about State of the Union on Jimmy
Kimmel the answer of course is no but
they'll have on people who are just as
part as I say more partisan than I am I
mean I'll hit Trump when I think he's
wrong the pod save America guys I think
they actually have a shrine to Barack
Obama and every so often they open up
the curtains and they light candles in
front of that shrine it's pretty insane
they were on Jimmy Kimmel the night of
the State of the Union address to
analyze Trump State of the Union address
again bias in action and then you know
Kimmel demonstrates his own bias because
he decides that it's time for him to
push again I don't know who mate who
died made Jimmy Kimmel the moral
authority in the country I mean the guy
who used to have women grab him grab his
shorts and tell him what was in his
pants on the man show he's he honestly I
feel bad saying all this stuff like I've
hit Jimmy Kimmel so many times but it's
his own damn fault I mean he feels like
a nice person and I know a lot of people
who know Jimmy Kimmel is he's a really
nice genuine fellow and I feel like he'd
be a good guy to hang out with but this
idea that he knows that anything about
politics or that he's a moral authority
is really ridiculous he can have his
opinion but once he gives his opinion
then I get to knock him for his opinion
because his opinion is just wrong and
men
of these cases because it's not based on
the facts so in any case he he has a he
doesn't stick about how dreamers ought
to be let in the country and Obama Obama
was nice and Trump is cool never mind
the fact that Trump is about to let in
three times as many dreamers as Obama
ever was there's about to legalize that
many dreamers
so Kimmel decides that he's going to do
this routine where he has a bunch of
people who opposed daca meet a dreamer
family or he's gonna have a bunch of
people opposed daca meet a dreamer
family and this is how again this is
talking about bias in the media this is
this is it in in spades
this is Esmeralda and this is her
daughter rose and Esmeralda came here
how old were you when you came to this
country I was a teen you were two years
old parents brought you here from where
Mexico City from Mexico City you have a
baby now yes and you are a daca
recipient you signed up you did a
background check you were fingerprinted
you have a job yes you pay taxes yes you
go to nursing school how many of you
think it would be right for as marauder
to be sent back to mexico country that
she's never known okay and the idea here
is to show how mean these guys are and
of course two of the two of the people
who are there are wearing Trump hats
right one is wearing a hat that says
make California great again and another
one is wearing a hat this is make
America great again
and of course it's two white guys who
kind of looks lovingly and this is this
is the idea that it's a bunch of racist
who want to do this and then a woman
who's raising her hand as well there's a
black woman in the audience who's not
raising her hand to other women so the
females are the moral voices in this
panel now you can you can point out that
there are dreamers who listen what I
send Esmeralda back I wouldn't I mean so
long issues of benefit to the American
society but you can be in favor of a
policy and still know that there are
sympathetic people who may be who may be
hurt by the policy and that happens all
the time I'm in favor for example of
getting rid of Obamacare are there
people who benefit from Obamacare
clearly there are some people who
benefit from Obamacare and I get in
favor of getting rid of Obamacare I am
and the reason I'm in favor of getting
rid of Obamacare is because I think that
over the broad swath of human beings it
will be better for America to get rid of
Obamacare than it then to maintain
Obamacare but this is the way the media
bias is the cases they like would they
ever do this with a bunch of people for
sanctuary cities like what Jimmy Kimmel
ever have a bunch
left-wing activists from San Francisco
sit there and talk to the families that
Donald Trump mentioned during the State
of the Union address ever would that
ever happen would he ever just have the
two families remember they're the two
black families whose daughters were
murdered by by an illegal immigrant
what would he ever have those families
confront people who are fans of
sanctuary cities of course not of course
not this sort of media bias is what
frustrates so many people on the right
and it's what I think wrongly allows
them to engage in a reactionary politics
where they say that all in losses fake
news or de ride anything the media ever
say but when members of the media do
this routine particularly members of the
cultural media do this it makes us all
nuts and it should make us whole nuts
because it's it's sad to say but Jimmy
Fallon who's the most apolitical of the
hosts has fallen in the ratings
specifically because he is the most
apolitical of the hosts because left
wingers are now tuning in to Jimmy
Kimmel to get their feel-good moment for
their leftist politics in a way that
they are not for Jimmy Fallon I'm not a
fan of either Kimmel or Fallon fact I
think Kimmel was funnier than Fallon but
I think that a political comedy is is
going by the wayside here and that's
simply too bad so again I think that
this is this is just more evidence of a
media that's biased they they hold up
they they set up situations deliberately
in order to achieve certain results I
talked about this a little bit on Dave
Rubens show with Jordan Peterson
yesterday what the media do in order to
gain results and that's why people like
me people like Jordan you know that
people like Sam Harris we mail disagree
on politics but if we refuse to accept
the bait that the media are presenting
if we refuse to acknowledge the
situation that the media are putting us
in in order to try and drive us to a
certain conclusion we're seen as
outliers and this is I think why there
are so many people who listen to us the
media's setup routine is getting old and
I think most people know it okay time
for a couple of things I like and then
some things that I hate so let's do a
thing I like see we're doing Bach this
week I'm one of the great pieces of
music of all time of course the same
path at the st. Matthew Passion by
Johann Sebastian Bach one of the
wonderful things about bhavas Bach was a
deeply deeply religious guy and that
comes through in his music one of the
things that that is fascinating again I
just read this bronze biography now in
the middle of that biography that I told
you about and one of the things that's
fascinating is that Bach thought that
there was a system to music he thought
that there was a a natural ear to music
your your ear resonates to certain
melodies in certain harmonies which
obviously is true and he also felt that
there are certain rhythms and
counterpoints that your ear is attracted
to in other words there are certain
natural laws of music that you can
define using your reason if this sounds
very familiar it's because this was
basically the idea of the founding
fathers that natural law natural rights
were things that you could derive from
nature right there are self-evident
truths in government and they're
self-evident truths when it comes to
music and Bach felt this Brahmins felt
this Beethoven felt this Mozart felt
this all the greatest musicians in
history felt this as we moved away from
that notion that there's an objective
musical truth out there that can be
discovered and accessed and toward the
idea that all music is subjective music
has gotten significantly worse it is
impossible to listen to st. Matthews
passion than listen to pop music and
think that there is no objective
difference between the two there is a
very large objective difference between
the two and anybody who doesn't believe
that anybody who thinks all art is
equivalent that all art is of equal
quality or equal genius or equal beauty
those people are fools that again here
here's the st. Matthew Passion by Bach
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just an amazing piece it's very
long it's a couple of hours st. Matthew
Passion but it's it but it's a it's an
incredible piece of music ok time from
the sublime to the ridiculous time to do
some things that I hate so thing that I
hate number one numero uno so Tommy
Liron who was ousted from blaze after
she went on the view and talked about
why pro-life people were basically
stupid and now she is on sean hannity
show where she gives her final thoughts
which i think is an apt description of
her segment final thoughts so i think
she says she in any case Tommy I think
Tommy's a nice person I've met Tommy I
think that you know maybe she's maybe
maybe she's trying but this is not good
ok so Tommy
so Tommy was giving her response to Joe
Kennedy's response to the State of the
Union address and here is what she came
up with if you haven't yet had the
displeasure of watching that little lip
response to president Trump's State of
the Union I suggest you take some
pepto-bismol or some midol or whatever
you need to do to get through it because
it was pathetic and it was embarrassing
oh my god okay so she's going after me
she calls him a limp bleep and then she
also said something about how he was a
ginger or something I mean this this
idea that that Tommy leerin is some sort
of a thought leader for conservatives
should be humiliating to conservatives
I'm sorry Tommy Lehren is not a thought
leader for conservatives Tommy learn is
a pretty woman a beautiful woman who
says things I mean that's that's it
that's it
and she says inflammatory things and if
people resonate to that it's because
people have a short attention span but
Tommy has bragged about not reading
books okay one of the reasons you need
to read books is so that you have been a
response to Joe Kennedy than just that
he's a limp bleep ginger okay you need
some actual content as to why you think
that he's wrong otherwise we're not
having arguments we're just insulting
each other and it's just yeah I hate
this kind of stuff I really really do I
think that you know I listen I'll drop
insulting language every so often but
nothing of that magnitude and I attempt
to support my arguments not with insults
but but with actual data conservatives
if you're young conservative and you're
looking for somebody to look up to I'm
not saying you have to look up to me you
don't there are plenty of people to look
up to all I'm saying is that you should
probably steer away from the people who
do this kind of stuff and just read a
book it's just it's not worthwhile okay
other things that I hate so apparently
there's an immigrant group that decided
to watch from State of the Union address
and to demonstrate their their cultural
sensitivity I guess they decided to
throw shoes at the wall this is what it
looked like
[Music]
[Applause]
it's so funny see cuz they're throwing
shoes you get it cuz it because they're
like throwing shoes now what's funny
about the throwing shoes things this is
not an American thing the throwing shoes
thing I mean like there's no history of
Americans throwing shoes at the wall
when people speak the last time I
remember somebody throwing and she was
actually when George W Bush was in Iraq
and in the middle of the press
conference a guy threw a shoe at him and
Bush ducked out of the way remember that
and but but this is I think
demonstrative of the level of vitriol
and anger that people hold against Trump
and his policies imagine if Republicans
did this there'd be talk about Obama's
president there'd be talk of they're
promoting violence they're promoting
assassination they're promoting actual
physical harm toward the presidents of
the United States people do this against
Trump and suddenly it's totally fine
so vitriol exists on all sides but it's
only called out on one and that's one of
the places where I have a serious
serious problem okay final thing that I
hate so there's a great article by
Katherine Kirsten over at Weekly
Standard describing the social justice
factory in the city of Edina so Edina
Minnesota has a public school district
and these public schools have now been
unraveling academic rigor why because
they're they're actually mandating that
students read books like children small
children read books like a is for
activists and this is for like tiny kids
like kids who are third graders a is for
activists T by the way in that book is
for trans which is something you
definitely want to be teaching about the
seven-year-olds about and then there is
that they make posters with gay rights
flags and they make posters with police
brutality and black lives matter right
apparently according to the Weekly
Standard the shift began in 2013 when
Edina school leaders adopted the all
four all strategy plan a sweeping
initiative that reordered the district's
mission for academic excellence from
academic academic excellence for all
students to racial equity equity does
not mean equality or fairness it means
racial identity politics an ideology
that blames minority students academic
challenges on institutional racial bias
repudiates Martin Luther King's
colorblind ideal and focuses on
uprooting white privilege so what to do
it mandated that henceforth all teaching
and learning experiences would be viewed
through the lens of racial equity and
that only racially conscious teachers
and administrators should be hired
district leaders assured parents this
would reduce Adina's racial achievement
gap which they attributed to barriers
rooted in
constructs and cultural
misunderstandings absolute nonsense by
the way that if you teach people about
black lives matter it closes the racial
gap there's no evidence of this
whatsoever so now they start teaching
kids about white privilege in
kindergarten so k2 students participate
in the melanin project students trace
their hands color them to reflect their
skin tone and place the cutouts on a
poster reading stop thinking your skin
color is better than everyone else's
everyone is special and then they have
racially conscious an elementary school
principal who runs a blog for the
school's community and they put up
pictures of protesters holding a banner
proclaiming gay marriages are right I
mean this is just ridiculous of course
description for an 11th grade us
literature and Composition course
required it says quote by the end of the
year you have learned how to apply
Marxist feminist post-colonial and
psychoanalytical lenses to literature oh
happy happy day how about like learning
to read how about that and we're making
kids useless before they even have a
chance to become useful it's pretty
amazing you wonder why the homeschooling
movement is gaining steam this is one of
the reasons that the homeschooling
movement is gaining steam by the way
here's the data for years into Adina's
schools equity crusade black students
test scores continue disappoint there's
been about a single positive point of
data black student reading scores for
all grades have increased from forty
five point five percent proficiency in
2014 to forty six point four percent
proficiency in 2017 so it just
marginally right black students on track
for success in reading decreased from
forty eight percent in 2014 to forty
four percent in 2017 math scores
decreased from fifty percent proficiency
in 2014 to forty-seven percent
proficiency in 2017 black students on
track for success in math decreased from
fifty-one percent in 2014 to 44 percent
in 2017 in high school this is the
scores dropped the most math scores for
black students in 11th grade at edenia
senior high dropped from 31% proficiency
to fourteen percent proficiency in 2017
and in reading in tenth grade at Edina
from 52% in 2014 to 40% in 2017
so well done everyone valuing the
stupidity of identity politics above the
glory of learning this is what you end
up with no shock parents are pulling
their kids out of school if my kid were
in that district I'd pull my kid out of
those schools as well alrighty well we
will be back here tomorrow presumably
with more on memo gate 2018 the fight
can
Jews will be back here with all the
updates I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing